حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انا شبه
جزيره القرم ومقاطعتي كالوجا وبلغراد
تعرضت لهجمه بالمسيرات هذا وقالت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه الى ساعات الماضيه
شهدت قصفا مكثفا بخمسه صواريخ مجنحه وشن
اكثر من 30 غره روسيه على مناطق مختلفه من
البلاد كما اكدت الاركان الاوكرانيه انها
وقواتها مستمره في الهجوم يعلم محوري
كما صدت هجمت الروسيه في مقاطعه دنيا حول
هذا الموضوع من تحديدا ينضم الينا مراسل
الجزيره نور الدين الدغير ومن سلبيانسك
مراسل الجزيره مازن ابراهيم لنرصد ابرز
التطورات الميدانيه على الجبهات المختلفه
ونبدا معك مازن ابراهيم
[موسيقى]
من مجموعه من المصادر المستقله بالاضافه
في المقابل الى محاوله التقدم روسيه في
كوبياس ومن الواضح ان هنالك بالفعل تقدم
في كوبيانك على مستوى مجموعه من البلدات
والمناطق المحيطه بالمدينه لصالح القوات
الروسيه على مستوى ما يحصل في تحديدا مركز
دراسات الحرب الامريكي اشار الى ان هنالك
معطيات موثقات تشير الى ان تمت تقدم لقوات
الاوكرانيه في محور في محور الروبوتينو
تحديدا حيث اشارت الى ان كامل تقاطع
المعطيات سواء كانت من الجانب الاوكراني
وفق مصادر ميدانيه مباشره او حتى بالاشاره
الى مصادر روسيه ترتبط بمعاينه لصيقه
للواقع الميداني من الواضح ان هنالك تقدم
ضمن عده كيلومترات في هذه المنطقه لصالح
القوات الاوكرانيه واشاره الى ان المصادر
الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن ان القوات الروسيه
استعانت في ذلك المحور بقوات احمد
الشيشانيه او ما يعرف بقوات احمد
الشيشانيه التي دخلت الى ذلك المحور في
محاوله تقدم القوات الاوكرانيه صحيح ان
هذا التقدم حتى الان لم يؤدي الى متغير
استراتيجي ولكن من الواضح ان هنالك تغير
على مستوى في المقابل بطبيعه الحال فيكم
الواقع مختلف محاولات تقدم روسيه واضحه
وهو ما دفع السلطات الى اجلاء الالاف وطلب
من الالاف الالاف المواطنين الاجلاء من
كامل البلدات المحيطه بكوبيانسيك
مثل ما استهل حديثه مازن ابراهيم قال بان
المسيرات اضحت روتينيه الى حد ما ولكن
الملاحظ وبحسب اعلان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
هناك
تنويه حتى في الاماكن خلال الساعات
الماضيه حديث رسمي عن شبه جزيره القرن عن
بيلورد وايضا كالوجا المحاذيه لموسكو
نعم محمد كنا قد تحدثنا عن ذلك في وقت
سابق على ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول ان
توسع جبهه المواجهات مع روسيا وان تنقل
المواجهات من البر الممتده من الشمال
والشمال الغربي الى الجنوب الى المواجهات
الجويه عبر استعمال المسيرات وفي المقابل
يكون هناك الرد الروسي عبر استعمال
المسيرات المسيرات وكذلك الصواريخ
المتطوره والفائقه السرعه اذا هذا
الاستهداف هذا الاستهداف الذي تقوم
بالقوات الاوكرانيه ربما عندما تاملنا على
مستوى الحدود هنا نتحدث عن
كورسك وعن بريانسك هاته المناطق التي ربما
تحاول القوات الاوكرانيه ايجاد ثغره امنيه
وتغرى عسكريه من اجل دفع القوات الروسيه
على الاقل للتراجع في الجهه الشماليه
والشماليه الغربيه التي تعرف نوعا ما
تقدما للقوات الروسيه اذا هناك ضغط حتى
السلطات العسكريه هنا والسلطات الامنيه
تتحدث على ان القوات الاوكرانيه حاولت
خلال الفتره السابقه اعاده ترتيب اوراقها
في هذه المنطقه على مستويات عده على مستوى
قوات المشاه على مستوى قوات الاختراق التي
تقول بان هناك حتى اجانب يوجدون في تلك
المنطقه وربما حديث عن محاوله توغل لهذه
القوات التي تصدها القوات الروسيه هناك
قوات مدفعيه يتم الحديث عن استهداف لمواقع
داخل الحدود الروسيه وخاصه حينما نتحدث عن
بيل غورد وسقوط سبع قذائف خلال النهار
كذلك محاوله مسيرات باقتحام هذه المناطق
بهدف ضرب المواقع الاستراتيجيه ومواقع
الدعم اللوجستي المساله كذلك لا تختلف
كثيرا اذا ما توجهنا الى الجنوب باتجاه
البحر الاسود وباتجاه شبه جزيره القرم
هناك بكل تاكيد محاولات اوكرانيا لضرب
مجموعه من النقاط التي تبدو اكثر اهميه
بالنسبه للجانب الاوكراني هو اكثر اهميه
كذلك للجانب الروسي هناك محاوله استهداف
مواقع للذخيره الروسيه باعتبار انها تشكل
الشريان الاس لامداد اسطول البحر الاسود
وكذلك لامداد الجنوب الروسي في المواجهات
القائمه هناك سواء فيزا او في الخرسون
وكذلك ضرب ايجاد نوع من الثغره الامنيه
على مستوى الموانع بهدف كسر الحضور
العسكري البحري للقوات الروسيه وربما
ايجاد ثغرات بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه
لتجد ممرا لاسطولها من هنا اذا هناك صراع
اسطل في تلك المنطقه لكن الجانب الروسي
لحد الساعه يتحدث عن كل هذه المحاولات
بالطائرات المسيره كان مصيرها الفشل سواء
باستهدافها عن طريق انضمامات الدفاع الجوي
او كذلك عن طريق التشويش الالكتروني لكن
بكل تاكيد محمد هذا ينعكس بشكل كذلك على
مستوى الجبهات وكما اشرى الزميل مازن هناك
تقدم واضح للقوات الروسيه على جبهه
كوبيانس وهناك محاوله صد واقامه
حواجز صد لمواجهه اي تقدم للقوات
الاوكرانيه سواء
بخرسون بالتحديد في جنوب دنيتك
شكرا جزيلا
وبتاكيد نشكر مازن ابراهيم مراسل الجزيره
وقد كان معنا من سلوفيانسك